[Music]
[Applause]
God don't call it a comeback he's Reggie
Miller
oh okay
uh Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer he's
on the call for Miami and Milwaukee
tonight and you are back
[Music]
Reggie sent me a text about a song he
wants to have played a walk up you got a
walk-up song
it's been a while so anytime it's been a
while you gotta have a walk-up song and
that's LL Cool J all right badass where
do you want to start
where do you want to stop first of all
let me ask you a question all right
when did
hitting dudes in the junk become a thing
what did they not do it in your day
no but maybe they did here's my thinking
because of technology and everything has
gone to video replay you have the
ability to do that
maybe got well guys are getting caught
now maybe they did it back in my day
because we didn't have these
modern advances so maybe they did but
this is weird don't you think well Chris
Paul's been doing it for quite some time
right this isn't just now with Dylan
Brooks or Joel I think it's just that
well I'm going back to when I played I
didn't play with Chris fall Okay so this
this generation he's part of this
generation but so when did this
generation but let me ask you about the
the villain now as opposed to the
villain when you play because
Draymond Green wants to be a villain he
Embraces it Dylan Brooks is blaming the
media that now he's being viewed as a
villain I embrace it if you know if
you're Dylan Brooks and you want to be
known for this because nobody cares if
you score 18 points but they care about
you or you you get people talking about
you back in your day
a villain was
what a tough guy Charles Oakley Rick
Mahorn Anthony Mason but my Davis boys
yeah but but they weren't here here's
the thing about being a villain because
there's being a villain and being a
villain with game I think I was vilified
but I had gain I talked a lot of trash
but I could back it up I don't think
Draymond Green is a villain because he
to me I put him in the same categories
of Someone Like A Dennis Rodman Dennis
Rodman was a villain but Dennis Rodman
had games he could back it up Draymond
Green has gained you're not a defensive
player of the year if you don't have a
game you don't win four championships
and I know people are gonna say well you
know he's playing with Steph and and
Clay you don't win four championships
without having a game so I'm not putting
Draymond Green in the the whole villain
thing because he has accolades the
backup yeah but he plays Rodman wasn't a
dirty player Rodman was just I don't
know
I thought he was alive you could ask the
mailman if he's if he's dirty old he
just tangled up with mailman I thought
he was I thought he was brilliant you
could ask the cameraman if he's well no
that was wrong that was okay yes but
Draymond is kicking people on the floor
draymond's a villain he's a great he's a
very good player he's going to be a Hall
of Famer he's going to be he has game to
back it up he's going into the Hall yeah
Dylan Brooks is not going into the Hall
okay why doesn't Dylan Brooks just if if
you want to talk trash about LeBron or
disrespect him don't then not talk to
the media and then blame the media for
how you're viewed
by you know the officials and you know
the public in general
uh Theodore first let me say this I
think that was a brilliant move by Dylan
Brooks I really do that it was brilliant
because what he was what he was trying
to do was blow up the whole Lakers game
plan because he thought he could get
LeBron to fall for the bait he thought
LeBron was going to fall for the bait
trying to come out be aggressive and get
away from the game plan which is to
force feed Anthony Davis because the
Lakers are only going to go as far as
Anthony Davis will take him his greatest
LeBron is the greatest player of his
generation top three top two player of
all time
he was trying to get him to rip up the
game plan come after me and for the
Lakers to go away and LeBron didn't fall
for it and you saw the beat down they
put on on the Grizzlies so actually it
was a brilliant play by Brooks to come
out and and do all this and say all that
well you can say it LeBron wasn't going
to fall for it and I said that on the
show he doesn't care about Dylan Brooks
and the game plan is not to put up 40 on
him he's correct yeah it's 30 12 and 8.
yes yeah Anthony Davis can put up 40 and
that would be part of the game plan here
uh yes how does this play out tonight
Lakers
here's the thing I I think jaw and The
Grizzlies figured out something
especially in the fourth quarter
that they've got to play the pace has to
be much higher and when you were getting
beat down like that in the first half it
was a humbling experience and I think
the Grizzlies figured out we got to play
faster and y'all look good I mean 22
consecutive points
but can he do that for an extended
period of time for 48 and then and then
make shots
um
it's all in the Lakers court right I
mean this is a chance for you to squeeze
hold of this series go up 3-1
um it is going to be a fantastic matchup
you gotta win this game you got to win
this if you're the Lakers this is it
because you don't want to go back and by
the way we are calling game five back in
Memphis so I'm looking forward to that
so selfishly it would be nice if Memphis
won and it was 2-2 but if the Lakers win
and going 3-1 it's obviously it's a must
win for for the Grizzlies
you got game four tonight Miami against
the Bucks and do you know if Yiannis is
playing we do not know I would assume he
is because very much the same way we
were just talking about Memphis and the
Lakers
tonight's the night this is it for the
overall number one seed in the playoffs
the the Milwaukee Bucks because if you
lose tonight and go down 3-1 teams that
are down 3-1 have gone on to win 95 of
the time so I would assume in my heart
that Yana's place tonight also
questionable tonight for the heat is
Jimmy Butler I think he heard his glue
um in game three so that's going to be
something that they're going to monitor
but all the chips if we're playing poker
if you're Milwaukee all the chips have
to be in the center of the table tonight
and I think Giannis plays tonight and
because they can't afford to go down 3-1
because it's a wrap
the Warriors and the Kings the Warriors
gave Sacramento everything and
Sacramento went toe-to-toe with them
which has to be encouraging for them
going back home what do you take away
from this series so far after four games
be careful what you ask and wish for
because leading up to these playoffs
everyone was trying to get in line and
the Warriors will admit to this to get
that number six seed so they could go
against the Green Sacramento Kings who
hadn't been in the playoffs for 17 years
and I kept telling people be careful
what you wish for because they've got
two things going for them
they're hungry
and they've got youth on their side so I
knew going against
Golden State they've got a head coach
who knows every bit of that organization
inside and out in Mike Brown and they've
got a guy in the Aaron Fox
speed kills and that's always been the
problem with
in terms of players that have generally
given the Warriors problems so Deanna
Fox was going to be a problem for them
and so bonus has been okay but it's been
in the Malik monks Murray had assignee
last night those guys Davion Mitchell
those guys have really put the hammer
down and I see this going seven because
that missed shot by Barnes yesterday
that could have been the end of the
Dynasty and I'm gonna and people don't
talk about this a lot about Stephen
Curry as great as he is the greatest
shooter our game has ever seen I want
people to give him credit on that last
play defensively he started off on Fox
kept him in front made him give up the
ball when Draymond Green came over and
challenged Barnes for that shot people
want to talk about the offense I just
want to give Curry love defensively that
was his best stop arguably ever in his
career on that last play Reggie Miller
Hall of Famer he'll be on the call in
Miami bucks in the Heat this just in
from Shams Giannis will be in the lineup
tonight barring any setbacks
game two and three he missed those with
a lower back contusion
and and even when he went down Miami was
in control of that game in the first
quarter and who's ever won the first
quarter has won the games game on it was
Miami game two Milwaukee won the first
quarter game three it was all Miami so
here we are tonight you've got the
two-time MVP a finals MVP hasn't played
the last really two and a half games
because he only played maybe a quarter
in game one
um let's see what his health is he only
knows how to play one way right with
Reckless abandoned so you know he's
going to be hitting the deck how does he
respond to that Theodore how does he
respond to the contact in the physical
play and the bigger question is can
Miami continue to shoot the basketball
this well 55 from the field they're
shooting 50 from three this office has
been terrible yeah all season long and
now in three games here in the first
round they found their offense can they
continue to shoot the basketball well
are you all in on the Knicks
uh in this first round I
I had picked them to beat Cleveland in
the first round just for the simple fact
three of the five starters for Cleveland
zero playoff experience and it it looks
like that they look like deer and
headlights especially playing in the
Mecca and if you're not ready for the
mecca it'll eat you up and that's
exactly what that Nick fan Basin team
has done so I knew the Knicks would win
this first round I'm more interested to
see how they will form in the second
round versus either one of these teams
Miami or Milwaukee that would be a fun
series to call and watch I've been
bringing this up with NBA guests here
the last two weeks I don't know why I'm
fixated on it but how will history
remember Kawhi Leonard
well you know what you can't erase two
championships one with a organization
that was used to winning with the Spurs
and he was more so known as a defender
on that team but that's why he won
Finals MVP because of the work he did
against LeBron
but look that Toronto run
came out of nowhere right no one
expected that and again I know Golden
State they had injuries during that
and what if what if KD didn't get hurt
what if uh clay didn't get hurt but you
can't control that you can only control
what I do what they did they ended up
winning the championship
um it hurts because I love Qui and I
know how much of a competitor he is but
again the game of basketball is not like
a light switch you can't just turn it on
and turn off when you want I've never
been a big fan of proponent of load
management I'm somewhat old school you
if you're able to play you play because
that's the way you condition your body
and him not playing a certain amount of
games and then you gotta just quickly
turn it on it's a shock to the system
it's a shock to the body I'm not saying
that's what led to this injury but the
basketball Gods know and if you can play
play that's kind of what I'm saying but
do you think that he has not it's not
fair to describe it this way but
played through injury to play actually
it's almost like he needs to be
right a certain percent
that that this hey I might play 60 games
this year that's the plan instead of
playing I could play Maybe 65 to 68 but
I might not be you know a hundred
percent eighty percent I can only speak
to myself and this is how I always view
things and injuries when I have a turn
ankle or whatever
me at 70 75 80 is better than a lot of
shooting guards at 100 that's how I felt
in my head Kawhi Leonard at whatever
percent you play at would be better than
most small fours slash power forwards at
any percent that would be the only thing
I would say to that because he is too
good too talented and at times no one is
a hundred percent this time of year
you've got to be able to play through it
to me that's what you got to be mentally
strong to play through it Theodore well
will history be kinder to Dwyane Wade or
Kawhi Leonard
definitely doing away Dwyane Wade played
through injuries
right they made a commercial about that
fall down six times get up seven they
make commercials about that better
player
well Dwayne has more championships right
three to two I believe right who do you
want starting for you
playoff game between no between those
two give me flash you take Dwayne Wade
over Kauai
give me flash okay what about if I gave
you novitsky
over Wade or coins or
are you gonna tell me who the rest of my
team is
that's your
that's your leader
game seven playoff
give me flash okay
give me flash
that dude give me flash man I think I'd
take Kauai
healthy yeah healthy coin now he won't
be there for game five or game six but
game seven he's gonna be there for game
seven and I'm gonna take him in game
seven
man
give me give me Dwyane Wade when he won
his first championship over Dallas
without LeBron without Chris Bosh give
me that dude I'll take that dude versus
anyone
are you sold on the sons
I am it's theirs to lose but how fun is
that second round matchup going to be
with Denver
cool win is it gonna be fun
oh yeah because here's the thing they're
gonna have to find an answer for your
kids well they're not gonna have an
answer they're not gonna have an answer
for him it's just Denver has to show up
as a team and that's that's where I get
nervous because I don't know kcp Aaron
Gordon
um Brown they've got three guys
they're gonna have to defend Booker and
KD
uh I think their their depth has helped
them
um I think it's going to be a great
that's going to be a six seven game
series
Durant but I'm still going with Phoenix
but is Phoenix led by Booker or led by
KD
to your point in the game seven Kevin
Durant okay he's the best player he'll
always be the best player on the floor
between the two teams
Steph Curry had a
bad moment there yesterday
what do you mean the timeout
what are you talking about he called a
timeout they didn't have a timeout again
he pulled a Weber it's not a Weber
because Weber was in a national title
game
this is a playoff game don't you have a
coach whose job is to tell you and it's
not the head coach you have an assistant
coach whose job is to tell you how many
timeouts it has nothing to do with
coaches Curry should know about you
should you're right he should know about
yeah he has nothing to do with the coach
telling him by the way we have no
timeouts all players know your timeout
situation so let's not say this is a
coach's fault for not telling one of the
greatest players of all time that you
had a timeout no I'm gonna I'm gonna
have one of our guys do an impression
you tell me if you know who this is okay
gotcha all right
a monster dunked by Giannis don't you
worry about his back the Greek freak is
back Milwaukee was down 6-1 at the start
and are now on a 12-2 run 13-8 bucks
with 736 left in the first Eric
spoelster wants to talk things over
we'll step aside and pay some bills
you're watching exclusive coverage of
the Eastern Conference playoffs on TNT
I think fritzy sounds more like Kevin
Harlan than Kevin Harlan does just
saying man the imitation is the
sincerest form where that is how's
the day how's the family
the family is great and they say hello
they are excited that we are starting
our month and a half Journey Dan s we're
back together it's going to be a great
playoff run apolly cue the music no no
no no no no no we we can't we we got one
that that the edited version is what we
need feel the music
come on
Marvin do you have the music
just
[Music]
do the beat you do the instrumental
come on
organization
[Music]
foreign
Hall of Famer yeah we got to get out
before uh hello slips one by the goalie
again uh he'll be on the call the Bucks
and the Heat tonight we'll uh get your
phone calls coming up take a break see
you reg back after this